it's Akademi award season which means
that all of Hollywood is buzzing about
that famous golden guy Oscar and this
year there's more reason than ever to
want to get your hands on one of the
coveted statuettes for the first time in
50 years Oscar will have a penis meet
Henrik buranovskiye a man who has spent
his life with Oscar in 1929 his father
handcrafted the first-ever Oscar
statuette as soon as he was old enough
Henrik began sculpting the statues
himself Stan what would you say your
grandfather's specialty is no doubt it's
the penis painting the lines of the
penis the shape of the penis the shining
of the penis the penis is his passion
his pride it is everything from 1929 to
1950 every oscar was crafted in the
barren now ski style complete with a
tiny penis as you can see here this is a
droopier european-style penis from
around 1933 oh this Oscar which is from
1938 has a corkscrew penis oh okay and
spun corkscrew yeah it's a spun penis of
course yeah oh and this is a very rare
Oscar with those stiff erect penis which
was only made for one year that was 1945
to celebrate the end of World War two
sothank was the dog no sadly in 1950
Henrik began to suffer from arthritis
making it difficult for him to perform
the precise delicate movements necessary
for sculpting Oscar's detailed penis
he says with his dexterity gone it was
difficult to graft the penis oh he said
dicksterity for years it seemed as
though the world would never again see
Oscars genitals but all that changed
earlier this year when Henrik underwent
an experimental hand transplant with the
new hand Henrik could once again return
to the penis sculpting he loved the
Academy took notice and last winter
Henrik got the call he'd been waiting
for they said to me hello are you the
sculptor of Oskar penis so not
celebrities lofaso not - it's an absurd
did I said yes yes I make the penis for
the golden man who first attested to
society - Chacon and then they asked me
to come back
[Music]
the varlets work if he could make small
golden penises all day long and into the
night for the rest of his days he would
die happy I hope you do die that way
I want you I hope I want you to die
jool Henrik Stan thank you both so much
for joining us and for entertainment
spotlights I'm Kay Donnelly
[Music]
you